is someone who's married to a doctor in
the medical field I think it's pretty
important to have a precise
understanding of what the words mean
just so that you can understand what
people are talking about if either you
are a healthcare professional or if some
healthcare professional is talking to
you as my wife does when well sometimes
does when she comes home from work so
let's get a little bit more precise with
some of the words we've been talking
about especially relative to heart
disease and heart failure and all of the
rest so let's say this is an artery the
blood is flowing in that direction I'll
show the artery branching off thins it
goes further and further along so this
right here is an artery and let me draw
a plaque in that artery and we've been
we've been studying these plaques in
arteries since the video on on heart
attacks so let's say this is a bunch of
white white blood cells and and lipid
material so it's cholesterol and fats
and all the rest now a word that you
might hear in kind of a medical context
is stenosis stenosis stenosis and the
word stenosis just refers to the
narrowing usually of a blood vessel so
this right here this blood vessel has
been narrowed so this right over here is
stenosis it's been narrowed by this
plaque it can also refer to the
narrowing of kind of any type of tubular
structure so if you have any type of
kind of pipe in a in a biological system
and it gets narrowed they might refer to
stenosis there but usually they're
talking about a blood vessel and this in
this example that I've drawn here it's
an artery so thus enosis is just the
narrowing is just the narrowing now once
once the blood vessel is narrowed that
restricts the blood supply so you aren't
able to get as much blood through it
you're not able to get as much blood
through it
so the blood supply is restricted so a
restricted blood supply restricted the
eye they're restricted blood supply this
restriction of a blood supply that
usually loses that usually leads to some
type of loss of function that's called
so this restricted blood supply this is
called ischemia another fancy word but
little
it just means restricted blood supply is
Kimia
now if you have stenosis in one of your
blood vessels in one of your arteries
and it restricts your blood supply so it
leads to ischemia then the muscles let's
say let me draw a muscle cell further
over here let's say that these are this
is a coronary artery that we're dealing
with the muscle cells over here are
going to get less oxygen so this guy let
me draw this cell right over here and
I'm just drawing an oversimplified
diagram I'm not going to imply that
muscle cells really look like that and
actually they won't be well I won't go
to the details here but this guy's not
going to get not not enough not enough
oxygen not enough oxygen so you can
imagine that if you know we're really
zoomed in onto the surface of the heart
we're looking at the heart muscle tissue
right here
if whoever his heart this was if they
started to go jogging or whatever and
this and this cell needed more oxygen
probably wouldn't be able to get that
oxygen because of the stenosis which
caused ischemia and because of that it
doesn't have enough oxygen so that the
heart it won't be able to help the heart
pump remember this is just one of the
muscles in the heart that's going to
help it pump the blood properly so it's
going to lead to heart failure heart
failure and once again the word heart
failure sounds more dramatic than maybe
it really is it sounds like cardiac
arrest where the heart stops but heart
failure is not saying that the heart has
completely failed it's just saying that
the heart is failing its ability to kind
of properly do its function so when this
guy goes jogging because he has a
restricted blood supply because it the
hardest experiencing ischemia down down
I guess downstream from this stenosis
that's why there's heart failure it's
not able to deliver now this heart
failure which is due to the ischemia and
this which is due to this stenosis you
would call this heart failure due to
coronary artery disease let me write it
we talked about battle-ax in two videos
ago coronary coronary coronary artery
disease
which is really just kind of a an imp
area of the hearts function because of
reduced blood supply because of a
narrowing in a blood vessel which
restricts the blood supply ischemia that
is coronary artery Dee's disease and
because of coronary artery disease when
this cell when this muscle cell and the
heart really needs to pump hard maybe
because someone's going up a hill or
climbing stairs it's not able to do it
because it's not getting enough oxygen
and that inability to properly for the
heart not just the cell but for the
whole heart this is just one of many
cells that maybe we won't be able to
pump properly for the entire heart to
not do its job that is heart failure now
you've also probably heard the terms
coronary heart disease coronary heart
heart disease or maybe just heart
disease heart disease these three things
are all the same thing these are all the
same they all imply some type of
narrowing or stenosis of arteries that
leads to ischemia reduced blood flow so
that the heart can't function as well as
that otherwise could now the last thing
I want to focus on and I talked a little
bit about it in the last video is the
idea of an infarct or an infarction
these are kind of funny words to say so
I'll write it over here so an infarct
infarct or infarction so in the example
I've drawn so far this this cell for
example maybe does not get enough oxygen
especially once the person is going
upstairs and all of that to properly
help to properly contract and help the
heart actually pump but it's not dead
it's still getting some base level of
oxygen less because of the stenosis and
the ischemia but it still gets some
oxygen and we saw in the video on
myocardial infarction or the video on
heart attacks that sometimes one of
these plaques might become unstable and
they break off and then you have a
complete you have a complete blocking of
a vessel a complete blocking of a of an
artery right here and we saw in the last
video we call this blocking what's
called an embolism and if it's due to if
it's an embolism is the general
for something that floated around and
then eventually blocks a vessel and if
it was due to kind of a released plaque
that also had clotting factors around it
after it got released that we would call
this a thromboembolism and this would
completely this would this would reduce
the the blood flow so much this reduces
the blood flow so much maybe a little
bit might be able to leak around but it
reduces it so much that the cells
downstream from this actually die so you
actually have the cell right over here
and this cell will die because it's not
even it might get very little blood or
no blood at all so it's not getting
enough oxygen to actually survive and
when you have dead tissue when you have
dead tissue that's due to a loss of
oxygen this is an infarct dead tissue
due to a loss of oxygen the process of
it becoming dead tissue due to a loss of
oxygen is an infarction and this
infarction this dead tissue due to loss
of oxygen in in in the myocardium in the
muscle tissue of the heart so now of a
sudden you have muscle tissue in the
heart that's beginning to die this is a
heart attack this is a myocardial
infarction so hopefully that clarifies
things a little bit